hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to three scary games
don't worry I'm not gonna spook you
right here at the beginning I wouldn't
do that I'm so nice and friendly and
happy I'm a friendly guy friendly guy
with friendly ways nothing to worry
about - three scary games welcome to a
stock liberdade did not get that but
whatever anyway this is a hey okay
alright I'll go this way
oh alright
shut i was very boring every single day
i ate the same food wore the same
clothes played the same games every day
i was this kind of person okay so uh
we're not so different after all
hey hey what the hell do you think you
are what do you think you are alright
fine then i'll go dissin way I'll show
you I'll show you the limit of my
madness I'll show you how persistent
douchebag I am oh hey what the hell
I see how this go now I see what's going
on here you think you're locked in here
with me turns out I'm locked in here
with you no wait no hang on
alright so I'm stuck I get it I get it
what of it what of it huh am I supposed
to do something about this this is only
moderately concerning been stuck on a
train well oh hey cards okay is there's
something in here that's useful to me or
am I
to stuck for life I'm a little confused
huh all right okay I guess I'll just die
then goose what do I do
very confused as to what I do
hi how are you hello good moose now or
Leno's or loss just Portuguese let's in
licks in can you read this quicksand
like seeing you must know a way out of
here you've got to know these are your
people you've probably been on this
train right you know you know oh whoa
what the hell okay I found something
some kind of a card
[Music]
oh okay tighten it I'm the genius
somebody by the name of Gabrielle
Gabrielle something something I probably
should have read it but I thought it was
oh hi
so you are the quim esta Oh
Gondo under vasista let's see it help oh
hi what the help all right
ding dong ring wrong hello I thought
someone was stomping up behind me
hello this feels like a wild goose chase
wink feels like I might die this
definitely feels like I might die
I sense death closing in at every moment
here oh hi oh hi hello I don't want to
buy any no thank you
blondes rather or not thank you for that
I appreciate it you're so nice and
thoughtful Wow
[Music]
there we go okay we we good we go cheese
one day I died a very stupid way to die
I'm not complaining boredom aphorism for
the accident oh that's not good that's
what you call not good that's that's one
of those not good things that's
definitely on the nut on the good - not
good scale that's that's not good
[Music]
oh oh that's not good
but guess what I'm coming back great
good that was so good Oh change language
oh I could have changed the language oh
wait no I didn't need to do it that I
had the right language okay that was
really well done
Gabrielle Nardi and Gabrielle Lovato
thank you all so I apologize if this
wasn't Portuguese licks Ian was it or
was it not Portuguese hey the wave it
very good very good all right
no I guess we're gonna move on to the
next game oh my god oh my oh my oh my
god oh no God what oh I think this game
is called cardiac Oh Oh I think about
hard aren't I I'm a heart oh god oh god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh god
this is awful this is the worst thing
ever oh God
all right everyone get over it we're
already into this if you're into this
you got to tough it out just tough it
out I'm suffering through you're not
even playing it so you can't complain at
all why do I get the feeling this is
made by the same guy that made that game
like the poopy game the game that was
entirely about butts and pooping what
did I do
why wait where am I now
oh my god what did I just crawl out of
him what did I just crawl it how did I
get to the sewers why was I in before
this is this is this horrible hellish
play is this vanish god damn it did you
guys trick me into playing vanish again
is that really what this is all about
cuz I swear I swear oh my god what is in
the pocket okay good great yeah okay
into the grey oh no wait
nothing to grab what
I'm sorry oh yeah of course the lighted
I'm on an airplane runway
any minute now an airplane is gonna
swoop in and squish me I don't think I
can move hello there we go there we go
I'm rolling oh now it's different I'm
rolling a little bit not very
inconsistently rolling I'm pushing a lot
of buttons in the buttons that used to
make me move or not making me move
anymore so there's a tiny speck in the
distance and I imagine I got to go
towards it but hmm for some funkalicious
reason and I do oh there we go there
there we go okay I had to point it
straight at the ground I see oh god what
the hell what the hell is that I thought
that was a tiny point in the distance
turns out it was not
I'm a soul mate I guess I found another
heart I am in love that's what it what
is there some deep emotional meaning
that I'm not getting out of this is
there something about the journey
through the clogged arteries of my own
heart a heart inside the cavernous Khan
caves of the human body forever destined
walked the lonely corridors of time
forevermore never to be truly satisfied
with the existence that was given to me
always to do my duty endlessly until one
day the system as a whole fails or I
fail the system I am an essential cog in
the machine but a machine I am there is
no hope in my existence
there is nothing got it what is this the
same crazy what I'm so confused
but my Confucianist its insurmountable I
cannot overstate just how confused I
really am I'm tremendously confused
outrageously confused I don't I don't
understand I don't understand I don't
understand I don't understand let me get
close to you it makes no sense I don't
understand but if I had to guess it's
the thankless journey that your heart
takes through this world with you your
heart speaks to you it has a voice and
it wants to speak out but it can't it's
silent in its journey perpetually
pumping blood throughout your body for
purposes that it truly doesn't
understand
now knowing from once a game but only
knowing that it shall do its duty to the
bitter end
despite the machinations of the system
as a whole the heart continues on as
best as it can even though it can be
betrayed from within who will never
betray willingly okay anyway I don't
know I'm gonna move on before I if
things get too weird but I believe I'm
gonna go I'm sorry just gonna move
pieces bring everything oh it's not done
oh it's not done okay all right cool
cool cool good good great that's good to
know good to know moving on whoa what'd
it be Lou it's be do ja ja good dog oh I
can't read this I don't know what that
means I don't know what any of this
means probably means like there's gonna
be jump scares or something or oh what
the hell what is this what is this
nonsense battery one huh oh hi put Prezi
Prezi Prezi a pair tazie for the guard
to turn on and off the lantern this is
Portuguese legs head okay okay yes so
that was what that was wait so I run out
of batteries when the thing is off is
that we okay I don't understand I don't
get it I don't know what's going on I
don't understand anything that's
happening I don't get it I don't know
what's happening okay so I turn it off
but I don't turn it back on too soon I
guess that's what I do
Seasons Christmas my heart okay so I
don't know the instructions be
why why okay I got it
okay I'll figure this out I guess oh all
right I don't know am i winning I'm
gonna give this one more try I don't
understand what you want for me it got
real quiet there and I don't know what's
going on I don't know I don't know I
don't know I don't know no no listen
don't do don't stop stop it stop it
stuff and stuff and stuff and stuff and
stuff and stuff it stop it stop it stop
it stop it stop it stop it I see you
there oh I'm alive I'm dead I have an
idea I'm gonna take a picture of this
open up yield google translate
and then try it again got the picture
so that all I'll try to type it in as
best I can into the old gooks and then
we'll see what happens okay okay it is
Portuguese let's see this is the
language of your people indeed oh yeah
you must know who are you okay Nandu
pero de se ho con you do we are go or I
take it OOP sorry ed a kid the Matar I
mean listen you already know this you
summon the Bell you made a wish to him
and he did it but Cove
oh not cold voz
but you fulfilled what he sent for the
completed wish and now he wants to kill
you okay all right Casso vrb do Oh
- League a lose at a race a massive safe
car come la la da de de da cemeterio de
Sarita de matar if you see Balu turn off
the light until he goes out but if you
are alone with a flashlight off it will
materialize and kill you
well that's what I did Balu B listen
Balu I got a bone to be loo pick with
you
you're gonna be lose a battle with me
here we go I'm gonna do this is what I
did before but I don't know what
happened oh oh my god
oh my god it's impossible I have
translated it and I still can't beat it
I don't give one more treasure but this
is the last try this is the last try I
swear there's the last time be lose
gonna beat me I'm gonna beat loser Balu
Balu big inside loose undulation I don't
know I hear it doesn't mix I wait why is
it silver
I give up I give up you loot you win
Balu you win Balu I love you Balu I hope
you win goodbye alright that was pretty
good but I have no idea who made it not
a clue
not a clue Balu not a clue so yeah that
was good I I dislike it like it got me
every time and I don't know that many
games can say that yeah that was epic
Balu oddly enough another Portuguese
game in a freak stop stop oh
oddly enough another Portuguese game in
this three scary games I didn't plan it
that way
did I no probably not but thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know you thought down in the comments
below and if you want to see more scary
games or more three scary games check
out the playlist linked in the
description
it is the scary games playlist filled
with hundreds of chariots top so check
it out for yourself or in the suggested
videos there's likely more scary games
for me so thank you again and as always
I will see you in the next video
[Music]